(tense music)
- So, I hear you
have a sex story.
- I do.
- Something happened,
something went wrong.
- [Voiceover] Take
seven, AB mark.
- I unraveled it to throw it out
and the condom was gone.
- No!
- [Voiceover] All right,
we're speeding and rolling.
- We barely, barely
avoided mom walking in
on son getting B.J.
which would have been--
- My favorite porn.
- For about the first 30
seconds, it was basically
like the best until
she began to shriek.
- [Voiceover] Roll cameras!
- There was this one
time where I thought
I killed a girl with my penis.
(dramatic music)
- Omarion.
Every R&B song, I feel,
is about how smooth
and cool and fucking
good at sex they are.
I met a bunch of guys
who have these stories
of like shit going down
when they be fucking.
- Right.
- And I feel like there's no
representation of them in R&B.
- Oh my God, this is my
area, you know what I mean?
Trust me.
I'll write this for you.
- Do you think we
can make this a hit?
- Definitely.
♪ Not safe, y'all
♪ Omarion
♪ Glaser
♪ With Nikki Glaser ♪
- Gross, son.
- [Voiceover] On my period.
- [Voiceover] So I'll
stick it in your ass.
- [Voiceover] Where's the lube?
- Yes, I can.
♪ Glaser, Omarion
♪ Best friends ♪
- Are you serious?
Dude, you fucked a girl
so hard she passed out?
These guys are losers,
they need help.
What are you doing here?
You have a tribal
tattoo and a six pack.
Go back to Equinox
you beautiful asshole.
♪ We're going number
one with this one ♪